can we reproduce our civilization on
Mars
if we were to construct a machine that
is made up of humans
like a company that can reproduce itself
yeah I don't know it feels like like
like 115
people
I get so much harder than that
120.
I believe the Twitter can be run by 50
people uh
I think that this is going to take most
of like it's just most of society right
like we live in one globalized world no
but you're not interested in running
Twitter you're interested in seeding
like uh you want to see the civilization
and then because humans can like oh okay
you're talking about yeah okay so you're
talking about the humans reproducing and
like basically like what's the smallest
self-sustaining colony of humans yeah
yeah okay fine but they're not going to
be making five nanometer chips over time
they will I think you're being uh like
we have to expand our conception of time
here going back to the original uh time
scale I mean over across
maybe 100 Generations we're back to
making chips no if you seed The Colony
correctly maybe or maybe they'll watch
our
Colony die out over here and be like
we're not making chips don't make chips
maybe you have to seed that Colony
correctly whatever you do don't make
chips chips are what led to their
downfall
hmm
well that is the thing that humans do
they they come up they construct a devil
a good thing and a bad thing and they
really stick by that and then they
murder each other over that there's
always one in the room who
murders everybody
and usually makes tattoos and nice
branding do you need that that's
a question right Humanity works really
hard today to get rid of that
but I think they might be important yeah
this whole freedom of speech thing it's
it's the freedom of being an
seems kind of important right
man this thing this Fab this human Fab
that we constructed this human
civilization is pretty interesting and
now it's building artificial copies of
itself or artificial copies of various
aspects of itself that seem interesting
like intelligence
and I wonder where that goes
I like to think it's just like another
stack for life like we have like the
biostack life like we're a biostack life
and then the Silicon stack life but it
seems like the ceiling
or they might not be a ceiling and or at
least the ceiling is much higher for the
for the Silicon stack oh no I don't I we
don't know what the ceiling is for the
biostack either the biostack the
biostack just seemed to move slower
um you have Moore's Law uh which is not
dead despite many proclamations uh into
house stack or the silver in the Silicon
stack and you don't have anything like
this in the biostack so I have a meme
that I posted I tried to make a meme it
didn't work too well but um I posted a
picture of uh you know Ronald Reagan and
Joe Biden and you look this is 1980 and
this is 2020. yeah and these two humans
are basically like the same right
there's no there's no like like they're
there's been no change in humans in the
last 40 years yeah and then I posted a
computer from 1980 in a computer from
2020. wow
yeah with their early early stages right
which is why you said when you said the
Fab the size of the Fab required to make
another Fab is like uh
very large right now oh yeah but
computers were very large
um 80 years ago
and they got pretty tiny
and there people are starting to want to
wear them on their face
in order to escape reality that's the
thing in order to be live inside the
computer there put a screen right here I
don't have to see the rest of you